all right let's see you did not type in
anything there let's do it again okay
I'm thinking this scene needs a bit of
explaining so you've probably noticed
we're all wearing masks because well you
now must wear a mask mask
everywhere you go but one slight problem
I realized Apple's face unlock feature
aka face ID doesn't let you into your
phone when a mask is covering your nose
and mouth mass number one believe me
I've tried many many masks a handmade
mask and tried retraining the whole
system many many times not letting me
that's when I came across I'm Danielle
Baskin and what do you do I'm a product
designer what are you talking about with
me today back in February Danielle had
the funny idea to print faces on masks
because she had heard about that face ID
and mask issue there was just one slight
problem with those it turns out though
that face ID actually uses instead of an
image so I ended up making a mask that
actually has a contour of your face that
can work with a city and does that work
yes it works I had to see it to believe
it and since I'm sheltering in place in
New Jersey and Daniela's in San
Francisco I made her demonstrate it via
video chat a lot I even made her get out
a mirror to make sure I wasn't being
played that's way better well I believe
you yeah
so this mask isn't exactly easy to make
first Danielle had to make a clay form
of a nose and mouth
it wasn't even hers then she made a
plastic shell using a vacuum former
machine when the mask was ready she
enrolled it as an alternate appearance
in the face ID settings on her iPhone
Apple said in the statement face ID is
designed to work with your eyes nose and
mouth visible users can still unlock
their devices while wearing a mask by
entering their passcode when I tried to
enroll my face using an n95 mask and
these various other cloth masks
number two three or I got an error
saying my face was obstructed but with
Danielle's mask the true depth camera on
the iPhone and the face ID software
appears to recognize the geometry of the
face in fact it even works when she has
sunglasses on okay ready
yep Wow this is also different from what
many have tried to do okay fine I tried
to do by creating a mask of someone and
then attempting to trick the phone
this isn't trickery it requires you
enroll the mask as one of your faces are
you planning to make leaves and Sally's
what's the plan no time soon I'm not
there's a shortage of PPE
so I would not capitalize on making any
masks if there is a value to making
these or people that work at hospitals
I'm interested in developing it so yeah
you're not getting one of these soon
which leaves you with two options keep
trying to get face ID to like your
current mask or type your password over
and over and over yes with gloves on
which I confirm do not require any
special clay molds or special machinery
[Music]